[Musique]
Je me sens incroyablement loyal et responsable
envers l'émission originale.
J'ai un grand désir d'
être même dans la même pièce que cette émission
parce que
George a changé la donne et son écriture a eu une énorme
influence sur
moi. C'est un sentiment incroyable.  pour réaliser mon
travail de rêve
[Musique],
vous recevez ce super appel qui est la
chose que chaque écrivain espère
vous dire que nous allons faire ce
truc et vous êtes heureux pendant quelques secondes
[Musique]
et puis vous réalisez le  responsabilité
qui repose sur vos épaules
[Musique]
je suis excité
c'est toujours un peu inquiet quand
vous confiez votre bébé à des
parents adoptifs mais je suis impliqué dans ça
c'est génial d'avoir Ryan qui est un grand
écrivain et quelqu'un qui connaissait vraiment mon
monde il est  va faire de son mieux pour
rester fidèle aussi
je savais que miguel sipatrick était un
réalisateur incroyable il avait voulu emmy il avait fait certains
de nos meilleurs épisodes
il y a toujours un peu de suspense quant à la
qualité de ce que ça va être
mais je pense que je suis  entre de bonnes mains ryan et
moi  guel
l'idée de retourner à westeros était
presque trop un défi
vous devez commencer par le respecter vous
ne pouvez pas commencer par faire différent pour
un souci différent
il a vu certaines des choses que j'ai vues et
ce n'était pas juste une préquelle  pour l'amour de la préquelle,
il y avait en fait une raison de raconter
l'histoire,
c'était vraiment de la voir sous un
angle différent qui m'intéressait, les
hommes préféreraient mettre le royaume au
flambeau
et voir une femme monter sur le trône de fer
[Musique]
le travail de george est vraiment un vraiment
monde immersif il y a des recoins profonds inexplorés
et des milliers d'années d'
histoire
réalisant ce qui a fonctionné dans les téléphones ce qui
n'a pas
que voulons-nous améliorer comment voulons-nous
faire évoluer
les plus grands ensembles que j'ai jamais été sur les
plus grands sites que j'ai jamais été  sur la
plus grande croisière que j'aie jamais vue, c'est
stupéfiant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous voyons vraiment le monde créatif de
manière très similaire,
nous allons commencer d'une
manière plus intime et plus ancrée, nous
allons partir et continuer  gre  à l'aventure
ensemble quel grand nouveau chapitre dans la
saga game of thrones
vous